l'air hagard les habitants découvrent ce
matin l'étendue des dégâts
certains immortalise les rues englouti
par les eaux d'autres s'affairent déjà
une sauver ce qui a sauvé pompant ce
couple de restaurateurs s'est laissé
surprendre par l'inondation
à l'intérieur plus d'électricité
réfrigirateur vaisselle et garde-manger
tout est engloutie on va pas pouvoir
ouvrir 120 sans électricité les pieds
dans l'eau qu'on ne prend pas on prend
pas faire tourner le commerce toute la
nuit confiait et secouristes ont évacué
les personnes les plus fragiles comme
dans cette clinique menacée par la crise
un à un les patients sont ramenées sur
des embarcations entouré d'autres ctc
unis l'empathie des sur une île certains
sortent à peine du bloc opératoire genou
droit opéré donc qui va est évalué au
service de ce matin certains habitants
étaient encore prisonniers des eaux
tout juste ont-ils eu le temps de
prendre quelques dents vous avez un
minibus de la ville de chalette qui va
pouvoir vous emmener le milieu des
affaires
franchement on est choqué ce qu'on voit
que ça monte ça monte dans la maison on
essaye de sauver un maximum de deux
choses vont à la part dans la vallée du
loing près de 500 personnes ont été
évacuées et plus de 3000 foyers sont
privés d'électricité